восьмий місяць оборони бахмута місто де
триває найбільш кровопролитна битва
російсько-української війни
у місті не стихає канонада артилерії
мінометів стрілецької зброї Бахмут
оточений з трьох боків росіяни
намагаються стиснути лещата і перерізати
останні шляхи постачання ЗСУ Утім
українські військові продовжують тримати
місто
вітання з українською бахмута
фортеця тримається
ліс Сиротюк один з оборонців бахмута
солдат гранатометник п'ятої окремої
штурмової бригади його підрозділ
перебуває на півдні міста де росіяни
зокрема пвк Вагнер намагаються
перерізати трасу Костянтинівка Бахмут
одну з останніх артерій для міста нею
доставляють усе воду їжу боєприпаси нею
ж підвозять і вивозять людей видно що
дуже важка зараз оборона
сказати що це все дуже просто і нам так
все легко вдається обстріл з трьох боків
артилерія постійно працює над головою
рухатися на по відкритій місцевості
практично неможливо тому що росіяни
стріляють хаотично за словами ветерана
АТО Євгена дикого армії РФ закінчуються
снаряди тож росіяни більше не можуть
активно застосовувати тактику вогняного
валу руйнувати будівлі артилерією і не
залишати заєсу позиції для оборони
натомість кидають у бій Якомога більше
людей за даними українського Міноборони
росіяни щодня втрачають 500 осіб убитими
це так звана русская трихомовка або
штрих-слойка це коли просто женуть з
гарматне м'ясо коли одна хвиля просто
завідомо лягає Тобто їх фактично
списують ще до початку бою друга хвиля
завідумо лягає а тільки вже третя
заходить на позиції оборонців тому що
оборонці за цей час втомились бо є
комплект закінчується та навіть банально
стволи перегріваються коли ми говоримо
що захисників бахмута засипають струпами
то в даному разі це не літературний
образ це от ну це прямий опис ландшафта
президент Володимир Зеленський запевняє
що ЗСУ контролюють усі ділянки фронту
водночас в офісі президента не
виключають що українські військові
можуть відступити від бахмута не більше
вигідні позиції такий варіант розглядає
і військовий експерт Густав грессель
проблеми полягає в тому що хоча все ще є
дороги що ведуть до бахмута які не
підпадають під прямий вогонь російських
військ ми перебуваємо на відстані одного
російського прориву від такої ситуації
якщо росіяни це зроблять то Українські
сили в бахмуті а також цивільні особи
які ще залишаються в місті опиняться в
пастці
потрібно вжити запобіжних заходів щоб
усунути таку можливість
або заздалегідь евакуювати гарнізон з
бахмута або здійснити контратаку щоб
відтиснити російські війська
Утім таку контратаку треба було б
починати зараз інакше ситуація буде дуже
критичною
[музика]
поки офіцій
но провідвід українських військ із
бахмута немає деякі експерти вважають що
воно вже може бути ухваленим Утім про
такий крок не повідомлятимуть аби не
давати переваги противнику на думку
Євгена дикого узсу ще є шанси прорватися
на півдні якби вдалося відкинути ворога
за кліщівку шляхи постачання до міста
Можна було б захистити і далі тримати
оборону водночас рішення відійти від
бахмута за словами військового було б не
трагічним але складним
із прифронтових одразу стають фронтовими
тобто такими як зараз Бахмут одразу три
великі міста це Костянтинівка це
Краматорськ
з військовою точки зору тримати оцю
міську агломерацію славянск-краматорська
її можна руками навіть пригожин оцінює
що він що він би штурмував цього
агломерацію півтора роки однак тоже він
півтора роки дасть тому тобто з
військової точки зору це не проіфронта
це не обвал Та це навіть не вихід на
кордоні Донецької області Зовсім ні але
з гуманітарної точки зору це доведеться
вивозити населення що трьох великих міст
Кожний з яких більше замахнет і знову ж
таки Ну і оця Нова лінія фронта по е-е
цих трьох містах вона буде довшою ніж
нинішня лінія фронта е по бахмуту себто
вона потребуватиме більшої кількості
людей на думку Густава греселя для ЗСУ
важливо берегти сили для майбутнього
контрнаступу тож відхід на більш вигідні
позиції був би непоганим кроком
Українські війська вже підготували нову
лінію оборони в глибині вони відійдуть
до неї звісно віддавати будь-яке місто
боляче тому що його треба буде знову
відвойовувати в певний момент часу але у
військовому плані нічого не зміниться
росіяни просунуться на кілька кілометрів
і все на захід від бахмута є хороші
позиції які можна обороняти
натомість у журналіст Юрій Бутусов який
не раз бував на позиціях ЗСУ у бахмутії
регулярно спілкується з військовими
вважає що до нинішньої критичної
ситуації в місті призвели системні
помилки командування комплектуванні і
застосуванні військ а втрата міста може
призвести до стратегічного погіршення
позицій ЗСУ на Донбасі Бахмут Звичайно
що
не варто було звідти відходити оскільки
конфігурація фронту в районі Солідар
Бахмут рельєф був абсолютно на нашу
користь це були в усіх сенсах дуже
зручні позиції там були зручний рельєф
висоти наш бік
вигідні комунікації велика щільність
забудови яка дозволяла розташовувати
значну кількість військ тобто в принципі
все це було на нашу користь і те що ми
не змогли реалізувати треба чесно собі
визнати що це проблема не кількості
заліза
ніколи не може бути стільки боєприпасів
На війні як нам треба коли 70 тисяч на
місто Бахмут не вважалося стратегічно
важливим Але після семи місяців запеклих
боїв стало символічним для обох сторін і
рейс 3G коли імпорт місто є стратегічно
важливим попри те що в ЗМІ часто
говорили про протилеж по-перше для
росіян взяття бахмута стане важливим для
підняття бойового духу тоді як для
українських військових це буде
психологічно складно до того ж втрата
бахмута може підірвати Віру західних
партнерів у спроможності української
армії
велика військова цінність захисту
бахмута полягала у тому що росіянам
важко взяти місто оскільки вони
втрачають багато своїх переваг у
вогневій потужності Вступаючи в дуже
близький бій з українськими військами
але як ми бачили також у Лисичанську А
тепер і в бахмуті Вони намагаються
уникнути бої у місті
анатомість просувається на околиці міста
на відкритій місцевості на північ і
південь від нього і загрожують місту
намагаючись його оточити
проблема полягає в тому що не так багато
російських сил стягується в місто і
вступають у прямі міські бої що завжди є
перевагою для українців
Юрій Сиротюк який захищає одну з
критично важливих доріг для міста вважає
тривалу оборону бахмута недаремною
військовий каже що його підрозділ
готовий тримати місто поки є такий наказ
від командування вони мріяли там
наприклад до послання путіна біля
літачка зфотографуватися його
знаменитого бахмутського не вдалося
потім до 24 не вдалося потім Путін
ставив завдання до кінця лютого
звільнити Бахмут і найголовніше те що ми
виснажимо їхню армію тому що якби ми не
стримали тут під бахмутом ворога то
Путін Напевно що сьогодні проводив якісь
стратегічні наступи невідомо чи на Київ
чи на Харків чи на Запоріжжя але точно
він кудись би рухався а так він застряг
під бахмутом і замість того щоб вилізти
з цієї пастки яка фактично для нього є
пасткою вони отак лобом б'ються об двері
бахмута довести що вони це місто можуть
взяти
тим часом у практично зруйнованому
бахмуті досі залишаються близько 4 тисяч
цивільних серед них майже півсотні дітей
це дані Донецької ОВА
л поки ще житло ціле
поки сам цілий
поки що залишуся
А цей польовий госпіталь нагадування про
ціну яку Україна платить за кожен
сантиметр своєї землі тут надають
допомогу пораненим яких щойно евакуювали
з бахмута мої медики працюють практично
цього добового якщо не при
повномасштабному авторозгненні за 8-9
місяців ротації в середньому в мене було
десь
50-60-300 за 9 місяців то на зараз
за добу буває більше тому
дуже дуже багато роботи але вони в мене
краще вони рятують наших бійців і
забирають з того світу у нас група синий
человек у нас група з семи осіб
стало 6
тепер мінус я
тобто 5
четверо контужені
група Альфа вистояла